okay so we are going to talk a bit about
async io and python
so um it's about the async and await
keywords that were added a couple of
years ago
and how we can use them within python
and a bits
about what is the difference between
writing async io code
and writing threaded code because that's
another way of doing concurrency
so all this is about how can we speed up
our program how can we do things in
parallel
in order to improve the execution speed
so we have quite a bit of different ways
of doing concurrency in python
first there was multi-threading which is
the easiest way to do
concurrency then there was
multi-processing
which solves an issue if you need more
cpu
because one python process can only
consume one cpu
if you need to have multiple cpus
because your problem is very cpu
intensive
then you need multi-processing then
there's g events we're not going to talk
a lot about that
and then you have a whole lot of event
loop based implementations
like there's twisted which is probably
the oldest then a few others
and in 2012 we got async iu
so let's first start with training so
trending is pretty easy you define two
functions in this case lsmbop
and then you create two threads where
each time you say first the entry point
the targets alice the second time you
say target is bob
and you start in so if we execute it
then you see these two things are
running concurrently
you see both print statements they are
nicely interleaved
now things become more complex if these
threads
if they has have to um
coordinate with each other if they have
to exchange data somehow
like for instance in this example you
see that there's a global variable
counter and both threads are trying to
manipulate that variable
so um first we are doing an increment
and then we are doing a decrement
and both threads you see they're doing
exactly the same thing
and now we can try to execute this
so what you would expect is that for
every increment we do a decrement
so if we would print the value of
counter at regular points in time
we would always print the value zero one
or two
depending on when exactly we print the
value
so let's try that that's this script
you see it's not exactly the case right
now we're printing negative values then
it becomes positive again
and as we go on we
diverge more and more from actually the
zero value
so how is this possible
let's take this function so very simple
function with an assignment and an
increments
if we're going to disassemble this
function you can do that in python by
importing
this library and then you do this this
and you
uh pass f so that you see uh the
bytecode of that phone
this function then you see that actually
for the increment
that corresponds with these four
instructions
um that it's not really one instruction
an increment like plus equal zero or
plus equal one sorry
consists of these four instructions um
it has to do with how the the python
interpreter operates on the stack
but it's very interesting it means that
if we have two threads that operate on
that same variable
at any point in time between these
instructions we can go from one thread
to the other thread
which means that these two threads can
possibly interfere with each other
and that's exactly what's happening in
this example
so the way to solve that is by using a
lock
so you can create a lock and you
surround these blocks where you
modify that shift variable uh with that
with lock context manager and then you
prevent these two threads from
manipulating the same variable uh at the
same time
so what is wrong or what is the
disadvantage of
using threads is that when as soon as
you have
to manipulate shared data structures you
have to think about locking
and that's something which is very hard
to get right so either you
choose to use one global lock
but then you have the rest that you lock
too often like things that could go
in parallel that these things become
sequential or you use
very like many small fine grained locks
like for each data structure you create
one lock uh
to to protect that from being modified
by other threats
and then you have the risk of dead
locking there are ways to prevent that
uh like some some guidelines and so on
but it's very hard to get right
and then threads they have some overhead
not a lot
uh so it's not really a main reason not
to use threads but still they have a bit
of overhead
i should also mention that instead of
using shared data structures
you can also not share data between
threads
but use some kind of message passing so
these threads they can communicate
over a queue and so if one thread has to
pass data to another thread
you can send it over the queue and
serialize it that's a way to prevent
using locks and prevent these issues but
it's also a whole different way of
programming
so let's come to async io
we're going to have a look at how we can
do these things in async io
so here we have also two functions
function one and function two
and we are going to run these in
parallel and do the same thing the same
increments and decrements
now you see that these functions are not
normal functions there's async
in front of the dev keyword which means
that it's an asynchronous function
and then there's an awaits as well
now what the await keyword here actually
means
is that that is a place where it's fine
to go from one function to the other
so basically we are in control when we
do the complex switching between these
two functions
so if we are now going to execute this
these two will run concurrently
but the complex switch between these two
functions
they will only happen at the place where
we have an await keyword
uh there is a sleep that's not important
right now but it's just to make this
example work so let's
this example you see we always print
zero
that's what you get when you would
execute the script
um so the await keyword
actually it means that it's a place
where it's safe
for one core team to move to another
core team
that's it basically now
in practice it means a bit more than
just that it also means that you're
probably
waiting for some io to complete because
the problem that we typically try to
solve with async io
is a very i o intensive application
and when you have many things going on
in parallel a good point to go from one
core team to another core team
is when you're idle when you're not
doing anything like for instance you do
a network request you wait for the
response to arrive
in between you're not doing anything so
that is exactly the right place where it
makes sense to go to another core team
and resume the execution over there
and so actually you will go back and
forth between all these curtins
at the point where you haven't await so
you have total control
over the context switching
so basically the difference between
threads and quarantines is that
threads that are preemptive and the
operating system decides when to context
switch
with coroutines like what we have in
async io
we are in control over the context
switching
and that means that most of the time we
don't have to use locks
because we know what pieces of code are
anatomically and won't be interrupted
that's exactly where we don't have any
weight and so
um it's much easier to get your coat
right
wave trending there's a lot of chance
that you get things wrong that
in production at some point things will
start breaking
with async io it's easier to get things
right
now important to know is that all of
this
runs actually on top of an event loop so
decorating
an abstraction on top of an even of an
event loop
an event loop that's a very simple
mapping where you map
io completion events to callbacks so
like for instance uh when a network
socket
becomes ready for reading or writing
when you receive most
keyboard events these are events and
then you
specify a callback that will execute
when that event happens and that's
literally
this while through so you wait for a
file descriptor to become ready
file the script maps to an event and
then you
call the corresponding callback and you
keep doing this in a loop
so if you keep this in mind then you see
that we only run
one callback at a time right and that's
really the advantage of event loops
these callbacks
they won't interfere with each other so
we run everything in one thread one
callback at a time
i've said there's no complicated
synchronization like data locking
and so on it's also pretty easy to debug
because if you put a break statement in
your code
your whole event loop will freeze and
you can inspect the state of all crites
and this is great also for handling many
connections in parallel
like if you have thousands of
connections like web sockets connections
and the idle most of the time then event
loop is perfect
because you can wait for so many file
descriptors at the same time
your operating system can do that for
you and then you execute the callback
that corresponds to the incoming
network connection from where you
receive a message
and that is of course much cheaper than
having one thread
for every single connection
one important thing to know though is
that you should not mix
async io code with traditional or
like the typical blocking code that you
find in other applications
like for instance if you use the request
library for doing network requests
that's what many people do in python
they will block you do a request and
your statement will
your request will get statement will
wait for the response to arrive
if you try to do that in an event loop
your whole event loop will freeze so you
cannot do that
there are workarounds to still execute
that kind of court but it's best to
avoid it if you can
um so we shouldn't we should not do
blocking io
instead we should do non-blocking io
by registering a callback in that event
loop which will then execute
um when a response arrives for instance
now these coroutines are an abstraction
on top of event loops it's pretty nice
so that you don't have to think about
all these callbacks because otherwise
you would end up with a very ugly code
so this is an example of what um
it's really hypothetical because this
library doesn't exist
but this is what a database query will
look like
in async io code so we do a query
we wait for the response because it's
like a networking
in between and when the response arrives
that thing will be assigned to users at
this point
so the await keyword here means that
we wait for the response to arrive we
return to the event loop the event loop
can then do other things in between
and when the response arrives the event
loop will resume the execution of this
function so it's like kind of a state
machine
the await will suspend it and later on
we resume it
so we do actually two things with or
wait we say
we can go to another function but we're
also waiting for the response
we can also use the await to call
another core team
like for instance here we have a main
function and we have a get users
function
and the main function is call and get
users but get users
is an async function which means that if
you call it
you don't get a response but actually
you get a quarantine object
and you have to use a weight in front of
it in order to get
actual uh result so the await keyword is
very often used
to await the outcome of another core
team
you see at the very bottom there is
async io.run that is how you start an
async io program
you need to have an event loop that gets
started and that will
like operate these uh quarantines that's
what
the very last line is doing
uh yeah so async and await they very
often
go together like you see in this example
something else which is important to
know is how to run
coordinates in parallel because that's
the whole point of using async io you
want to
parallelize stuff and one way of doing
it is by using async io dot getter
so asynchronous is a way to
wait for the outcome of multiple
coroutines at the same time
in this case we spawned the get users
core team twice
and when both are done these um
the execution of the main function will
uh go on
so actually you can think of async
io.get as a join in threads you're
joining
multiple things together and actually i
like this way because
of doing concurrency i like this because
you have some kind of symmetry
you have a place where you start things
in parallel and things come back nicely
together
that's what you actually want you don't
want to fire something and then
forget about it it's very important
actually to do the join
in order to get some kind of symmetry
um if you cannot do that then you
could actually do async dot create task
that will spawn the quality
and execution in the main function still
goes on but if later on you decide you
need the response then you can still
wait for the task and you could actually
do users
equals await task to capture the outcome
of that
core routine but i think it's pretty
important to actually
not just spawn tasks and not wait for
the response
but instead really wait for the response
because
that way you can do proper exception
handling
if there is an exception raised and get
users using try accept
you can capture them around the await
statement
then uh there is also async with an
async 4
which are pretty nice so the web block
you probably know
as a context manager that's something a
code that you
execute before and after the block very
typically used for
establishing a connection and closing
the connection or
allocating resources and releasing
resources
so that's what webblock is doing async
with
is what you do if any of these two
blocks the enter
or the release involve async code
and in this case that's the case
establishing a connection
has to be asynchronous because it takes
some time to establish the connection
and
you need an async with in order to do
that
then async 4 is something you typically
see when you're consuming asynchronous
data stream
like for instance you select the users
from a database table
the entries are all transmitted over the
wire
over the network and you receive them in
chunks
not all at once so you don't want to
wait until the whole response arise
before you start processing
but you want to start processing things
as soon as possible as they arrive
so that means that every iteration of
the for loop
involves possibly waiting for the
network network response to arrive
and so that needs to be asynchronous
that's when you have an async
4 and these two are typically things
that you see
that you have to use for many async io
libraries
then there are executors which is also
something good to know about
so this is something you use whenever
you have to run traditional
blocking code it could be either a
situation where you have
um a blocking io library like requests
or it could be a situation where you
have very cpu intensive code
um in that case also you would block the
event loop
if you have something which is very
computational expensive you could run it
in a
other and have the main thread the main
event loop go on
and respond to incoming connections
so in this case the executor will run on
another thread
on another process and the weight can
still be used to wait for the
outcome of that piece of code
then one warning don't turn every call
into an
async call it's what people often get
wrong when they start with async iu
because some people think that at some
point every function will become
async because at some point every
function will involve doing io
right and often that is the case but
doing io doesn't mean that you have to
wait for the i o
for instance in the case of a logging
server imagine that you're logging to
remote server
then you don't have to wait for this
logging messages actually to be
transmitted you want the logging to
happen in your server
but you want your execution to go go on
as soon as possible
and so instead of using an awaits in
front of your login calls
is best to implement your login
framework in a way that
you push all your logging messages into
an async queue
and somewhere else you have then a core
team that consumes the queue and flushes
the messages
over the network and so that way your
functions
don't have to be async not necessarily
something else here which i think is
important
we should try to separate the
code that is doing io from the code that
is doing
computational stuff if that's possible
for instance
if you are doing a parsing library where
you're
parsing data that's completely
that can be written completely
independent from the i o layer
and so if you can separate these things
then you can have
code that is completely synchronous and
an asynchronous code around it that
calls the synchronous code
and that's totally fine so try to avoid
ending up in a situation where every
function becomes async
this is next actual example i'm not
going to say a lot about this because
later today tom christie will talk about
httpx which is um async io library for
doing http calls
so if you're interested in that then
stay for a few more talks then
uh we will discuss this but you see that
here as well
we have the async web block for
establishing the connection
and then the await to wait for the
response
is something that you very often see
with these async libraries then
something else which is good to know
is that if you're experimenting with
async io
um you cannot oh
you cannot uh just use an await keyword
in your interactive shell
if you try that that would be a syntax
error because you can only use an await
in an asynchronous function and it's
very cumbersome for trying out async io
code
but there's the solution ipython does
support
um async io integration which means that
in
ipython you can use the await keyword
top level
and then ipython will ensure that the
event loops runs and
so it's very great for experimenting or
you can do python
and async io it's also very it's
basically the same thing but then with
the normal python shell
so to conclude async io is a pretty
great concurrency pattern
for io heavy applications not so much
for
cpu intensive applications but if you're
dealing with a lot of i o and many
connections then
async io is great it's not the easiest
to begin with honestly
but very often when things become more
complex it's it's
it is much easier than training to get
right
um and then the important pitfalls i
would like you to remember
try not to mix um
async io code with blocking io unless
you use an executor
and try not to turn every call into an
async call
so that's what i have i don't know
whether any
questions you can find me on twitter on
github
sorry yeah
this one geter can take as many
functions as you want
it takes them as positional arguments
you can
pass as many core teams as you want
together